question avec réponse évidente pour
certains mais qui peut aussi semblait
impossible pour d'autres est ce qu'il y
aura et surtout doit-il y avoir un zola
stuff est parti trois suite à la
conception du trois théories et puis mon
expérience sur le jeu j'étais tout le
temps en mode avec cette question dans
la tête et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il va
y avoir ensuite est-ce qu'il y aura une
suite
donc je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans
cette petite vidéo chill où j'aimerais
que nous parlions du futur de la saga je
vous invite bien évidemment laissé un
petit pouce bleus et surtout me partager
vos avis et vos idées via l'espace
commentaires et ce dans la bienveillance
bien évidemment c'est toujours un réel
plaisir d'échanger avec vous et vous
lire et the last of us de on est
vraiment la parfaite occasion
mince c'est dommage que j'ai dû la tuer
mais bon les jeux vidéo ça court pas les
rues maintenant espérons qu'elle joue un
bon je remets mon dieu mais mais ces
raids shadow légende un des jeux mobiles
avec certainement le plus d'ambition
disponible aussi sur pc red shadow
legend est un jeu très complet et
profond je vais pas vous mentir
j'aime pas trop les jeux mobiles à la
base mais c'est là où règnent shadow
légende se démarque
sa crédibilité est clairement son point
fort chaque champion est unique
les graphismes sont top et encore mieux
il y a même une campagne avec une
histoire sérieuse on pourrait limite
faire un trois théories pourparlers
gameplay vous pouvez jouer comme bon
vous semble et de la manière que vous
souhaitez créer votre équipe à votre
guise
parmi un panel de champion énorme avec
cette faction il ya de quoi faire moi
par exemple j'aime beaucoup les elfes
noirs
leur design est top et il me rappelle
des gros boss a la final fantasy
ils peuvent faire également de bons des
gammes zone pour certains mais surtout
il boeuf les alliés et infligent des
malus aux ennemis en plus déjà des
dégâts
le jeu se renouvelle sans cesse et c'est
quelque chose d'important pour un jeu
comme celui ci avec notamment une
prolongation des récompenses quotidienne
qui va même jusqu'à 270 jours bref
télécharger le jeu maintenant en suivant
les liens dans la description pour
obtenir une clé de bosses une pleine
énergie un boost expérience d'une
journée 5 éclat mystérieux 50 j'aime
cinquante mille pièces d'argent et le
champion gratuit bourreau pour les
nouveaux joueurs mais faites attention
ces récompenses ne sont disponibles que
pendant 30 jours donc c'est à vous de
jouer
bon neil druckmann celui qui a géré le
projet se lassent toughest partie d'eux
nous a laissés dans le vague en
affirmant qu'il ne serait pas s'il y
aurait un seul as tu fait partie 3 et
surtout qu'ils ne sauraient pas de quoi
il serait composé majorité de vous dire
normal la partie 2 vient à peine de
sortir et il nous faut le digérer pour
le moment et le découvrir encore pour
certains le projet a été un sacré
morceau pour naughty dog
après sept longues années soit la sortie
de the last of us premier du nom
beaucoup trop tôt pour l'affirmer
clairement et le but c'est de ne pas
savoir s'il va y avoir une suite
mais doit-il y avoir ensuite the last of
us est une saga à succès dans
l'entreprise the last of us 2 a fait un
démarrage record pour naughty dog et
c'est difficile d'imaginer que tout
s'arrêterait ici en termes de business
ce serait un peu se tirer une balle dans
le pied surtout quand on compare à une
charte id l'autre saga phare de naughty
dog qui en est déjà à son quatrième opus
principal
il est presque certain qu'il y aura
d'autres jeu the last of us mais est ce
que ce sera une partie 3 je laisse aux
fesses 2 s'est terminée sur une note
très mais alors très amer je vous invite
bien évidemment à voir entre eux théorie
pour plus de détails mais elie a fait
une incroyable escalade de violence elle
s'est laissé submerger par la haine au
point de tout sacrifier pour enfin avoir
la conscience tranquille
sauf que c'est tout l'inversé qui se
passera il y va tous perdre dina tommy
joël etc
et en plus la vengeance ne s'est jamais
réellement conclut habite toujours en
vie eli est allé trop loin et a
littéralement tout perdu quitte à même
de venir l'antagoniste de sa propre
histoire et c'est là que je m'interroge
est-ce une bonne idée de terminer là
dessus scénaristiquement parlant ce que
je veux dire c'est que la saga the last
of us est aussi proche du jeu vidéo que
du cinéma en soi
nous sommes sur une production quasi
hollywoodienne dans sa conception
la plupart du temps les oeuvres se
finissent généralement bien
ou du moins il y à une note positive
dans la conclusion pour les
protagonistes principaux
sauf qu'ici il n'y a absolument rien de
positif dans la fin des lits l'idée que
justement comme pour beaucoup d'oeuvres
vidéoludique la fin d'un épisode soit
amer pour justement amener une suite
avec une conclusion beaucoup plus douce
comme l'avait fait par exemple final
fantasy 10 avec final fantasy 10,2 par
la suite pour les connaisseurs en fait
la particularité de ce the last of us 2
et que la note positive la petite touche
d'espoir ne concerne pas et lis mes
habits dans le biais de sa traversée
avec lev jusqu'à santa catalina et c'est
curieux de nous laisser là dessus sans
avoir la moindre information
avec cette conception cela laisserait
sous-entendre que si une suite il y à
nous suivre lyon la nouvelle vie dhabi
en compagnie de laives dans le camp des
lucioles reformer mais est ce vraiment
un choix pertinent quand on sait qu'à be
est un personnage qui est vraiment
détesté par beaucoup et qui a vraiment
diviser la communauté et donc du coup
pas laisser elie sur le côté alors c'est
censé être l'héroïne principale de la
saga en fait le truc c'est que malgré
les points communs évidents entre les
deux opus la construction de l'histoire
et les objectifs du premier jeu et du
second sont assez différents laissez-moi
mieux vous expliquer dans le premier jeu
joël doit mener une mission très
importante
il doit livrer elie aux lucioles car
cette dernière est immunisé à
l'infection due cordyceps cette
livraison a pour but de ramener l'espoir
et même possiblement la société ce qui
est le but ultime des lucioles faire
renaître l'humanité face au problème du
cordyceps il y à un véritable enjeu
alors que le second opus nous propose
une histoire de vengeance totalement
intime pas de question d'humanité
les infectés sont mis au second plan et
l'immunité délit ne sert plus à rien
actuellement et c'est ça le point
important
the last of us 2 possède ce petit côté
frustrant car au final ils ne mènent à
rien de spécial joël moeurs eli est en
colère et veut se venger
au final la vengeance n'est pas à mener
jusqu'au bout et il y perd tout je suis
un peu dur dans mes propos mais c'est le
cas à contrario du premier jeu qui avait
vraiment le but de ramener l'espoir dans
l'humanité bref mais si au final c'était
voulu
reprenons la fin du jeu habib élèves
sont en quête des lucioles à santa
barbara
ils réussiront à trouver une radio ou
habits contactera les restes du groupe
qui se sont
formé sur l'île de santa catalina après
les crédits
le jeu nous montre une image du bateau
dhabi élèves ayant réussi à les
rejoindre pour quoi amener ceux ci
pourquoi nous ramener le groupe des
lucioles à la fin du jeu car il y aura
une continuité à toute cette histoire en
fait pour moi
the last of us 2 est un épisode
transitoire dans la cohérence on avait
besoin d'une histoire un petit peu plus
personnelle pour agrémenter l'univers de
the last of us mieux connaître ces
personnages la vie après l'effondrement
de la société
ce jeu est pour moi comme l'avant
dernier épisode de la série dark
je ne vais pas spoiler pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu la série et qui
comptent l'avoir mais c'est un épisode
qui va expliquer et développer tous les
moments entre le temps mettre en lumière
des éléments qui n'étaient pas
spécialement nécessaire pour l'intrigué
principale mais qui font un bien fou
pour la cohérence de l'univers et sa
compréhension
je ne sais pas si j'ai été assez clair
the last of us 1 avait un énorme enjeu
pour l'humanité the last of us 2 nous
propose une histoire plus personnelle
pour agrémenter l'univers et l'histoire
des personnages le fait maintenant de
nous ramener la problématique des
lucioles à la fin du jeu sous-entend une
suite ou les enjeux seront de nouveau
plus grands comme ceux de the last of us
1 car les lucioles en c2 symbolique de
postérité d'espoir pour l'humanité
la quête d'une solution donc oui il doit
y avoir une partie 3 ce ne sera
peut-être pas la conclusion mais nous
devons avoir une suite pour répondre aux
enjeux du premier jeu est ce que
l'humanité survivra et trouvera-t-elle
une solution ou n'y at il aucun espoir
c'est ça la vraie question mais voilà je
suis incapable de vous dire la
construction du prochain jeu cependant
l'idée la plus cohérente serait qu'on
suive le point de vue dhabi puisqu'elle
a rejoint les lucioles avec lev
néanmoins je ne sais pas si c'est un bon
choix au vu des réactions des joueurs
puisque beaucoup n'ont pas pardonné à
abbey
ou n'ont pas apprécié la jouer comme je
vous disais le cas de la rédemption
délit est assez probable étant donné
qu'elle est maintenant toute seule cette
dernière va très certainement vivre en
ermite pendant un certain temps des
lobbys one sur tatouine comme nous l'a
prouvé le second jeu cette dernière est
unique elle est enfin pour le moment la
seule à posséder cette immunité et sa
raison de vivre était pour elle
d'apporter le vaccin au monde
si conclusion il doit y avoir c'est bien
par rapport à elie et son immunité
la question de la survie de l'humanité
et la renaissance de la société tout est
éphémère dans the last of us personne
n'est à l'abri et on peut mourir à
chaque instant ce n'est vraiment pas un
monde pour vivre une longue vie paisible
malgré ce que pourrait laisser croire la
ferme où jackson
nous sommes toujours poursuivi par notre
passé nos démons il ya toujours une
raison de se battre
ce n'est pas ce que je souhaite mais si
elie devait mourir si sa mort était la
conclusion à toute la saga imaginée son
sacrifice pour enfin créer un antidote
pour l'humanité un vaccin qui aurait
pour nom
joël
[Musique]
bon je vous avoue qu'on est un petit peu
dans le fantasme mais le véritable
problème avec ce the last of us partie 2
et qu'il a vraiment beaucoup trop divisé
les fans et donc s'il ya une suite
elle devra réunir ces derniers justement
c'est ça toute la problématique
the last of us 2 n'est pas parfait je ne
suis pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il ya
dedans même dans la mise en scène dans
la conception etc bref je respecte
l'oeuvre de neil druckmann naughty dog
est libre de proposer ce qu'ils veulent
et moi je suis client c'est tout
néanmoins s'ils doivent faire une suite
il faudra quand même satisfaire un petit
peu les fans et les réunir pour que la
licence reste toujours aussi populaire
bref tout ça ne sont que des
suppositions et c'est mon avis personnel
et c'est à vous de me dire le vôtre en
commentaire dans tous les cas juste pour
revenir sur l'immunité des lits il est
possible que son immunité ne servent au
final à rien mais ce serait quand même
bien dommage pourquoi avoir cet élément
scénaristique qui semble si important
pour au final ne rien faire et qu'ils ne
servent à rien quoi aller j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu
ça fait du bien de se libérer un petit
peu sur la question de the last of us 2
et puis s'il y aura une partie 3 je m'en
suis toujours pas remis de joël
franchement c'est très dur à encaisser
je m'en remets toujours pas même un mois
après je pense vraiment qu'ils auraient
dû le faire mourir beaucoup plus tard ou
faire jouer à bille avant qu'on retrouve
elle y est c est ce que la c
enfin bref merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit peu de vous abonner et c7 et argo
rock et que le lionheart ce soit avec
vous
[Musique]